Générique
...
-Bonjour à tous
et bienvenue. Très heureuse
de vous retrouver. Aujourd'hui,
nous recevons
un invité exceptionnel :
Jack Lang.
Bonjour
et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation.
Avec moi
pour présenter l'émission,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour, Jack Lang.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes
président
de l'Institut du monde arabe
depuis 2013. Vous avez avant tout
une immense carrière politique,
commencée au PS en 1977.
Vous avez été député,
député européen,
maire de Blois de 1989 à 2000,
porte-parole du gouvernement,
ministre de l'Education nationale
sous Bérégovoy et Jospin,
mais pour nous tous,
vous êtes l'éternel ministre
de la Culture.
Vous l'avez été dès 1981,
pendant 10 ans,
sous tous les gouvernements
socialistes
pendant les deux septennats
de François Mitterrand.
On vous doit
la fête de la musique,
la fête du cinéma ou les journées
du patrimoine.
Le patrimoine,
culturel et culinaire,
vous y êtes attaché,
comme le dit votre menu.
-Oui, avec un totem
de la cuisine française :
un pot-au-feu.
En dessert,
une omelette norvégienne.
-Découvrez le fast-food
maghrébin.
On vous emmène
dans un bar à couscous
et plus largement
à la découverte
de la cuisine orientale.
-La galère
des restaurateurs
pour trouver du personnel,
en salle et en cuisine.
Comment rendre ces métiers
plus attractifs ?
Reportage à suivre.
-Allez, on passe à table !
-Monsieur le ministre,
d'abord,
merci d'avoir choisi
ce pot-au-feu qui, sincèrement,
nous réjouit.
Alors qu'arrivent
les premiers frimas,
le pot-au-feu est parfait pour
se réchauffer le corps et l'âme.
Mais avez-vous bien saisi le concept
de cette émission ?
Eh oui, quand je vous lis
à propos de ce plat populaire,
rustique, vous dites :
"Le pot-au-feu, c'est idéal
"pour travailler sur un dossier."
Là, il y a peut-être, et même
sans doute, un malentendu.
Si vous comptiez nous faire bosser,
sur vos prochaines expos
de l'Institut du monde arabe
sous prétexte
que l'on déguste un pot-au-feu,
je vous le dis,
c'est raté.
Pas question
qu'on se plonge
dans les poèmes de Jean Sénac
pour les tables rondes
du 17 novembre.
"Politiques, à table !" est
une émission, M. Lang,
plaisir, gourmande,
alors s'il vous plaît,
déconnectez
ce pot-au-feu
du boulot
et racontez-nous plutôt
votre passion pour cette macreuse,
cette queue de boeuf
qui fond dans un bouillon parfumé
et faites-nous visiter
les coulisses de l'histoire.
Est-ce que vous partagiez
des pot-au-feu
en 1981 avec le président Mitterrand
et tout le banc socialiste,
dans son fief du Morvan ?
-Oui.
Je lui ai même préparé...
J'aime cuisiner.
Je suis pas un grand cuisinier
mais j'aime cuisiner
et j'aime la cuisine rustique,
la cuisine traditionnelle.
-La cuisine du terroir.
-J'aime aussi
les recherches mais,
dans ma famille, le pot-au-feu
est un plat traditionnel
depuis toujours.
Et, dès que l'hiver approche,
en effet...
Je le prépare
avant. Il est bon que le pot-au-feu
dorme un peu un jour ou deux.
-Vous faites le bouillon
avant ?
-Je fais le bouillon, les viandes,
deux jours avant pour que ça...
-Ca macère un petit peu.
-Il puis il faut du temps.
Quand je dis
que je bosse, ou je travaille,
je gratouille,
pendant que le pot-au-feu
se prépare...
Prenez l'exemple de la queue
de boeuf, qui est un élément de base
du pot-au-feu, qui donne
un parfum, un goût, une saveur,
il faut cinq heures
ou six heures
pour qu'elle soit tendre.
-La joue de boeuf,
c'est dur à cuire. C'est long !
-Un peu moins.
Mais bon, en même temps,
j'aime ce qui caresse les pap...
Non seulement les papilles
mais aussi les narines...
-Le palais...
-Et le parfum
des légumes, du laurier,
du thym...
des... des légumes, m'enchante !
Et ça me donne du punch...
-De l'énergie.
-Qui vous a appris
à faire le pot-au-feu ?
-...pour écrire,
pour travailler.
-Qui vous a appris à le faire ?
Vous avez pris
une recette ?
-Ma mère était
une très bonne cuisinière,
ma grand-mère maternelle aussi,
et ma gourmandise
était le principal moteur.
-Vous êtes gourmand
ou gourmet ?
-Gourmand, et peut-être gourmet.
-On va le goûter
ensemble, vous nous direz
si c'est un bon
pot-au-feu, si vous y retrouvez
les pièces de viande
que vous avez l'habitude...
-Je vois à l'instant,
et c'est un bon point,
pour moi, pour le chef,
c'est qu'il a mis
de la queue de boeuf.
Peut-être... pas assez...
Pas tout à fait
assez cuite.
-Ah bon ?
-Parce que le pot-au-feu...
-Il faut que ça cuise
longtemps, c'est ça ?
-Et des viandes
gélatineuses, maigres,
différentes.
C'est quoi, votre panaché ?
-Ca dépend.
On discute
avec le boucher.
Mais là, vous avez réuni :
joue de boeuf,
plat-de-côtes
et queue de boeuf. C'est...
-Du paleron ?
Jarret ? Macreuse ?
-Le paleron, c'est une merveille.
Mais là encore, ça réclame
une cuisson lente et...
et longue.
-Dans l'eau froide
ou bouillante ?
Il paraît qu'il y a deux écoles
et que Paul Bocuse mettait
dans l'eau froide.
-C'est des histoires.
-Vous ne croyez pas
Paul Bocuse ?
-Non. Ce qui est
stupide,
c'est si on met des légumes
brutalement dans de l'eau glacée,
on les saisit, on leur fait du mal.
-Mmh...
-De l'eau, disons,
tiède ou froide,
ou chaude...
-Et alors, les légumes,
qu'est-ce que vous avez l'habitude
de mettre ?
-Légumes ?
Comme ici, donc, carottes,
j'entrevois navets
pommes de terre,
mais aussi poireaux.
Il y a trop peu de poireaux, là.
Bon, un peu de thym,
un peu de laurier...
Parfois...
Bon, c'est bien, voilà.
Et ce qui existe
dans la saison du moment.
-Et là, il y a
l'os à moelle.
-Indispensable.
Parce que l'os à moelle
donne un goût...
apporte, avec la...
avec la queue de boeuf
un goût...
fort et bon.
Simplement,
l'os à moelle,
le problème,
c'est qu'il faut l'envelopper
pour être sûr que le bouillon ne...
-Que la moelle
ne parte pas, aussi ?
-Et pour être sûr que le gras
n'envahisse pas la totalité du...
-Et l'os à moelle,
vous ne le mettez pas
au même moment que la viande.
-Pas au même moment.
Et les légumes non plus.
-Il y a tout un timing précis.
-Ce qui permet,
entre les 2, les 3 ou les 4,
de travailler.
-Et d'avoir une bonne
cuisson de tous les...
de tous les éléments.
C'est vrai qu'il y a des...
-Ca excite les sens.
-On est très excités.
-On revisite
aussi un peu le pot-au-feu.
Trois astuces pour...
"rocker" le pot-au-feu,
Jean-Pierre ?
-On peut le revisiter.
Par exemple,
on peut faire un pot-au-feu
en mode phô,
cette soupe vietnamienne.
Vous ajoutez
des clous de girofle,
des graines de coriandre,
de l'étoile de badiane
qui donne un goût un peu anisé,
des oignons de printemps
et un peu de sauce nuoc-mâm,
et votre pot-au-feu aura
des saveurs asiatiques sympathiques,
c'est à essayer.
-Là-dedans,
il faut mettre aussi,
dans le pot-au-feu "français",
il faut aussi
des clous de girofles
et quelques-uns des ingrédients
que vous avez évoqués à l'instant.
Exactement. Après, on peut se passer
du boeuf, s'il ne vous fait pas
d'effet.
-Dans un pot-au-feu,
se passer du boeuf ?
-Oui, c'est une méthode
de cuisson, on peut le faire
à la volaille, au lapin,
au veau,
saucisse de Morteau,
et même,
si vous voulez pas de viande,
vous pouvez faire
un pot-au-feu de lotte
avec des petits légumes
et cuit dans le bouillon.
Enfin, on peut aussi sortir
du triptyque qu'on vient d'évoquer,
navet, pomme de terre et carotte,
avec des vieux légumes :
panais, topinambour,
ou alors des patates douces.
-Ou des pommes de terre ?
-C'est souvent
dans la version classique.
-Un plat voisin que j'adore
et qui varie de province
en province,
c'est la potée.
Dans mon pays d'origine,
la potée lorraine...
-C'est votre pays d'origine ?
-La Lorraine.
Le lard y était très présent.
-Et alors,
ça, c'est un plat
que vous faites régulièrement ?
-Régulièrement.
Mais pas le seul,
quand même !
-Effectivement,
vous avez d'autres...
Vous êtes souvent en cuisine ?
-Quand je suis chez moi, je cuisine.
Ma femme me fait confiance.
Elle a peut-être tort.
J'aime ça. Et le dimanche,
généralement, c'est...
Ma fille, mes deux petites-filles
et quelques amis,
et le matin,
je vais au marché.
C'est un bonheur, le marché.
Regarder, déjà, sentir,
savourer, humer...
Et puis, je me mets
"aux fourneaux",
vers 11h,
mais quand c'est un pot-au-feu,
je l'ai préparé le samedi,
ou même
le vendredi.
-Et vous arrivez au marché,
vous vous laissez tenter
par ce que vous voyez ou vous avez
votre liste de courses ?
-Souvent, je sais à l'avance.
Par exemple, j'aime beaucoup
cuisiner le poisson
et le cuisiner simplement
au court-bouillon.
Le saumon, le bar, et d'autres...
-Le colin ? Très bon
au court-bouillon.
-J'adore le colin.
-Et après,
une petite sauce
ou juste nature ?
-Oui, ça peut être...
Par exemple...
Je garde de côté
des morilles sèches
que je mélange avec un peu de crème.
C'est simple, hein.
Ca peut être une mayonnaise,
mais allégée.
-Avec des blancs d'oeuf, là,
vous mélangez ?
-Absolument.
-Est-ce que vous cuisinez
à l'instinct
ou vous aimez un livre de cuisine
que vous suivez, ou vous avez
une espèce de...
de petite imagination
et vous partez dans le vide ?
-J'ai peu d'imagination.
Sur ce plan-là,
en tout cas.
Naguère, j'adorais lire
les livres de cuisine.
Pour les lire, pour les lire.
C'était une passion.
De même que j'aime lire
les dictionnaires.
Les vieux,
j'adorais...
Ma mère avait
le vieux Larousse
de cuisine d'avant-guerre,
que j'ai toujours chez moi.
De temps en temps,
je le compulse...
-Ca vous inspire ?
Ou des chefs
vous ont aussi inspiré
dans votre cuisine ?
-Il y a des grands chefs
que j'aime, que j'admire.
Je serais pas capable...
Si je devais citer un nom,
je dirais Michel Guérard.
Pour moi,
c'est le grand maître.
C'est lui qui a ouvert
la cuisine à la...
à la vérité,
à l'authenticité.
Et c'est un homme merveilleux
et généreux.
J'aime aussi,
pour d'autres raisons,
Alain Ducasse. Hier,
il avait convié quelques amis
à un dîner amical,
tous ceux
qui l'avaient aidé
à réaliser ce que vous verrez
d'ici un an et demi,
une sorte de maison
de l'artisanat
et un restaurant
à Clichy,
dans une maison
qui a été conçue
par un ami,
de Nancy, aussi,
Jean Prouvé,
qui fut un grand architecte
constructeur,
et le président du centre Beaubourg.
-De belles inspirations.
Ca donne quoi, après,
vous, en cuisine ?
La potée, vous en parliez,
le pot-au-feu.
Quels autres plats signature ?
-Je vous ai dit...
"Signature", n'exagérons pas.
L'important, pour moi,
c'est la qualité
de ce que je peux acheter
et la cuisson.
Le poisson est souvent
très présent.
Le soufflé, ou les soufflés.
-Au fromage ?
-Principalement.
Ou "aux fromages",
parfois.
Quelquefois, des soufflés sucrés,
au chocolat,
parce que ma femme
aime passionnément le chocolat.
Voilà. Et puis...
Et puis aussi les fruits de mer,
et puis aussi... Voilà.
-Vous avez une palette
assez variée.
-Oui, oui.
-Quel terroir a façonné votre goût
et vos inspirations ? Vous avez dit
que vous êtes né dans les Vosges,
vous avez été aussi
maire de Blois,
dans l'Eure-et-Loir.
Qu'est-ce qui a le plus marqué
votre ADN de cuistot ?
-Culinairement ?
-Oui.
-Hm.
-Naturellement,
c'est l'enfance,
l'adolescence...
Oui...
Et...
Mais c'était, au-delà
des plats traditionnels lorrains,
disons,
la quiche, comme on dit,
ou le pâté lorrain,
une merveille,
mais il faut savoir le faire.
C'est une entreprise héroïque.
Ou certains gâteaux admirables,
comme le succès,
qu'on retrouve maintenant dans
beaucoup de pâtisseries parisiennes.
Donc, mon inspiration vient
surtout de la Lorraine.
Et éventuellement...
De la mer, quand même,
car une partie de ma famille
est originaire
de Bretagne, de Vendée...
Par exemple, la cotriade,
autre...
J'aime beaucoup les soupes,
finalement.
La cotriade est un plat breton,
je pense, de poisson.
C'est une potée de poisson.
-De la bouillabaisse
de poisson ?
-Mais bretonne.
Les plats, tout ce qui est
à base de soupe
m'enchante.
Par exemple...
Dans beaucoup de pays,
vous trouvez l'équivalent,
mais avec les produits
du pays.
Il y a un pot-au-feu colombien,
dont le nom m'échappe,
qui est admirable,
mais réalisé avec les produits...
-De Colombie.
-De Colombie. Euh...
-Il y a d'autres pays,
comme ça,
qui vous inspirent...
dont vous appréciez
la cuisine ?
-C'est autre chose.
"Inspire"...
Je suis vraiment un amateur.
Je suis pas
un cuisinier, hein.
Non, alors, je suis, en effet,
passionné par les cuisines.
-Du monde ?
-Les cuisines du monde.
Je veux pas établir
de hiérarchie,
ce serait très prétentieux,
mais je dirais
que la cuisine en tête,
dans ma petite échelle
de valeurs :
la cuisine japonaise.
-Ah !
-La cuisine marocaine,
la cuisine maghrébine en général.
-On va en parler.
-Oui.
-La chinoise...
J'admire son extraordinaire
dextérité,
son incroyable diversité,
selon les régions,
mais elle est parfois
un peu lourde.
Mais quand même,
c'est une grande cuisine.
Et puis, même,
les pays dont on parle peu
ont chacun des choses...
L'Allemagne,
on a longtemps dit
que c'était un endroit
où on mangeait mal.
C'est vrai et c'est faux !
Quand vous allez
déguster une fabuleuse
saucisse de Munich,
avec du raifort
- le raifort est un
de mes condiments préférés.
Ca vient de...
Je sais pas,
de ma relation
avec l'Alsace...
D'ailleurs, chez moi,
vous viendriez, y a, en réserve
- j'ai trouvé un endroit où on peut
bien se procurer -,
des dizaines de préparations
de raifort.
C'est très bon,
ce qu'on peut déguster
en Allemagne.
-La forêt-noire, aussi.
-La forêt-noire !
Et même dans les pays
de l'extrême nord,
en Suède, en Norvège,
et l'Italie !
-L'Italie, c'est,
pour les Français,
la numéro 1.
-Ce qui est merveilleux en Italie,
c'est la simplicité.
Où qu'on aille,
ce n'est pas le cas en France,
sans ouvrir de polémique,
c'est pas le cas en France :
où qu'on aille en Italie,
on mange bien.
-Avec une cuisine du produit
que vous appréciez sans doute.
-Et ils ont un respect
du consommateur,
il n'y a pas d'attrape-touristes.
-Pas d'attrape-touristes.
-Peut-être à Venise,
par exemple, mais globalement,
c'est une assurance.
-Vous avez raison. L'Espagne,
c'est un pays incroyable...
Il faut faire le tour du monde,
un tour du monde culinaire
merveilleux,
et il y a des pays
que je ne connais pas.
C'est vraiment
quelque chose d'éblouissant
pour la vie,
cette relation à la cuisine,
mais au-delà de la cuisine,
à la vie, à la nature,
aux légumes...
aux épices.
-Votre façon de consommer
a évolué ?
Aujourd'hui, on dit
qu'il ne faut pas manger de viande
tous les jours, alors qu'à l'époque,
on en donnait beaucoup aux enfants,
car il y a plein de protéines.
Vous, vous êtes devenu
un peu flexitarien, comme on dit ?
-Oui. Peut-être
que j'ai été influencé
par les temps, en étant nouveau,
entre guillemets,
mais je consomme
moins de viande qu'avant,
et les légumes
me passionnent beaucoup.
-Alors...
-Euh...
-Oui ?
-Juste une question.
On n'a pas l'habitude
de vous entendre parler
comme ça de la cuisine.
Vous nous avez fait une fête
de la musique, pourquoi pas
une fête de la cuisine ?
-On a fait des choses
qui sont mal connues,
à la fois
comme ministre de la Culture
et ministre de l'Education.
J'ai créé, en son temps,
le Centre national
des arts culinaires,
qui associait plusieurs ministères
concernés par la qualité
de la cuisine :
le ministère de l'Agriculture,
le ministère de l'Education,
et le ministère de la Culture.
Je crois
que le premier président
de ce Centre national
des arts culinaires,
ce fut Robuchon...
-Ah !
-Ou Michel Guérard. Enfin,
l'un et l'autre l'ont été,
et nous avons impulsé
toute une politique,
par exemple, d'initiation
au goût dans les écoles,
en lien avec un homme admirable
qui s'appelait monsieur Puiset,
un homme qui, à Tours,
avait créé un institut
du goût. Nous avons,
avec un autre ami,
créé, en lien avec le CNRS,
une série de livres
qui mériterait d'être rééditée
sur les savoirs culinaires
traditionnels,
région par région.
-Région par région ?
-Région par région,
et ainsi de suite.
-Ca s'est perdu, à l'école ?
Vous n'avez pas l'impression
qu'il faut réenseigner
les légumes,
la façon de consommer,
de manger ?
-J'ai essayé de le faire
quand j'étais ministre
de l'Education nationale :
on a multiplié
les classes de goût,
j'ai essayé d'agir
sur les...
Ce n'est pas l'Etat qui décide,
ce sont les communes.
On a essayé
de les inciter
à choisir la qualité,
la qualité de produits locaux,
en particulier, pour les faire
découvrir aux enfants.
-C'est encore une question
très d'actualité,
de consommer local :
les cantines
ne sont pas toutes...
très bonnes. Ca progresse.
-Je n'ai pas fait d'enquête récente,
mais mon intuition me dit
que ça s'est plutôt amélioré,
je crois.
-Avec ce pot-au-feu...
-Mais,
c'est un vrai sujet.
Avec Michel Guérard,
dont nous parlions,
nous avions aussi mené une réflexion
sur la restauration collective,
c'est-à-dire à la fois
les lycées, les écoles, etc.,
mais aussi dans les hôpitaux,
et on l'a obtenu.
Lui-même, d'ailleurs,
avait créé, à un moment donné,
dans son lieu...
dans le Sud-Ouest,
une école
pour la restauration collective.
-Alors,
avec ce pot-au-feu,
vous nous avez demandé
un vin de Loire, un chinon.
On est en...
C'est du cabernet franc,
évidemment,
puis c'est un millésime 2017
avec une robe légère,
quelques nuances de grenat,
et des arômes de fruits rouges.
C'est une appellation
que vous aimez
particulièrement ?
-Je crois qu'il y a eu
un malentendu.
Ca ne fait rien.
J'aime beaucoup le vin de chinon.
Non, j'avais proposé...
-C'est une erreur.
-J'ai été maire de Blois
et député du département
de Loir-et-Cher,
donc j'avais proposé
de choisir un gamay
du Loir-et-Cher.
-Ah alors, c'est...
-C'est pas grave.
-C'est une erreur.
-On peut dire
que ces vins,
qui, il y a 30 ou 40 ans,
n'étaient pas toujours
très savoureux,
ont gagné en qualité,
en raffinement,
partout et dans le monde entier,
dans le monde entier. Par exemple,
on parlait de l'Allemagne,
il y a des vins allemands fabuleux !
Vous avez entendu...
En Angleterre, même.
-Oui.
-Oui. C'est pas forcément
une bonne nouvelle.
-Avec le réchauffement...
-Puisque vous cherchiez
des anecdotes politiques,
que je ne trouve pas facilement,
j'ai en mémoire un vin d'Angleterre
que l'ambassadeur
de Grande-Bretagne nous a offert
lors de la visite
de la reine Elisabeth à Paris,
au dîner d'Etat,
et il y avait un vin anglais,
qui, ma foi, était assez bon.
Ca s'est beaucoup amélioré encore.
-Et ça va encore s'améliorer.
On va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable et c'est le quiz.
-Jack Lang, vous êtes, Brigitte
l'a dit, président de l'Institut
du monde arabe et que serait
le monde arabe sans
le loukoum. Dites-nous
si ces affirmations à son sujet
sont vraies ou fausses.
Jean-Pierre Montanay lit
la 1re proposition.
...
-Qu'est-ce que je dois dire ?
-Si c'est vrai ou faux.
Que le monde
découvre...
-En 1906 ? Je ne sais pas du tout.
Je ne suis pas sûr que le loukoum
vienne d'abord des pays arabes.
Je pense
que le loukoum vient des pays
comme la Turquie, plus orientaux.
En plus, ça a été ensuite...
ça s'est développé.
-Ca s'est répandu.
-Le bon vrai loukoum,
c'est pas si fréquent.
-Vous répondez non,
c'est pas en 1906 ?
-Je ne sais pas.
-La démocratisation, non,
c'est avant, c'est
en 1873 lors de l'expo
universelle de Vienne,
elle reçoit une médaille d'argent
et c'était
un confiseur d'Istanbul.
-Vous voyez.
-C'est la tradition ottomane.
-On peut donner 1 point.
-Je suis pas complètement
nul.
-Alors, le 1er loukoum connu était
confectionné
avec du sucre, de l'eau,
de l'amidon de blé
et de l'eau de rose.
-Il y avait
du blanc d'oeuf aussi, non ?
Non, je me trompe.
-Peut-être que l'amidon de blé
pouvait permettre de faire le liant,
donc on va dire oui.
A l'étranger, les plus grands
amateurs de cette douceur
ottomane sont les Allemands.
-C'est possible, je n'en sais rien.
-C'est faux,
c'est en fait les Anglais.
Dès la fin du 19e siècle,
le loukoum colonise la culture
britannique. Il y a même
la multinationale
du bonbon, Cadbury,
qui avait essayé de lancer
un loukoum industriel,
mais sans succès.
Enfin, la reine Elisabeth,
toujours la Grande-Bretagne,
adorait les loukoums contrairement
à Churchill qui les détestait.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Je ne sais pas,
je dirais oui.
-Non, faux,
parce que Winston Churchill
adorait aussi les loukoums.
-Il adorait tout,
lui, le cigare, la bonne bouffe,
etc. C'était
un mangeur, un jouisseur...
-Il aimait les loukoums.
-On va parler de la tête de veau,
chère à votre adversaire politique,
Jacques Chirac.
-Et à moi.
-Une des spécialités
des Vosges. Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations sont exactes ?
Le berceau de cette recette est
Saint-Dié-des-Vosges.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Je ne crois pas.
-C'est faux, Rambervillers, où se
déroule la foire aux têtes de veau.
-Où je suis allé.
-C'est vrai ?
Alors, cette foire
a lieu le lundi de Pâques.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Je ne sais plus.
-C'est faux,
c'est 15 jours avant Pâques.
-Il faut être très fort
dans votre émission.
-Il existe même
une confrérie des Gaubregueux
Gousteurs de Testes de Veau.
-Je ne sais pas, mais je veux bien
en faire partie.
J'aime la tête de veau,
mais la vraie de vraie,
je ne sais pas
si vous allez en parler.
-Comme ça existe, on va leur faire
signe pour que vous y soyez intégré.
-Les Gaubregueux.
-Et puis la sauce gribiche,
qui accompagne
la tête de veau, est à base
de cornichons, oeufs durs,
ail et échalotes.
-Oui,
c'est une sorte de mayonnaise,
je sais pas très bien.
-Un peu, mais il y a pas d'ail.
-De toute façon,
j'aime tellement la tête de veau
que je ne prends pas d'aïoli,
je l'aime, la tête de veau...
-Nature.
-J'aime la dévorer nature
quand elle est bonne.
La tête de veau bonne...
-...partout.
Pardon ?
-On n'en trouve pas partout.
-Non, c'est très difficile.
La tête de veau,
ça va peut-être écoeurer
certains de vos auditeurs,
elle doit être cuite
à l'os, c'est-à-dire
totalement cuite entière. Et...
Et il y a très, très peu d'endroits,
je connaissais à un moment,
un endroit, Saint-Ouen,
un restaurant merveilleux,
où chaque mercredi, on pouvait
la déguster. Aujourd'hui...
Alors, je vais vous faire, je sais
pas si j'ai le droit de le faire,
je le fais, tant pis.
Un de mes amis, qui est
un gastronome,
un passionné de cuisine,
qui s'appelle Robert Reiplinger,
qu'il me pardonne si je cite son
nom, qui adore la tête de veau, et
nous... nous nous débrouillons
pour trouver un chef
qui nous la prépare
à la manière ancienne, c'est-à-dire
à l'os. Et c'est le chef... Ah !
Rue de Varenne.
-Passard ?
-Passard, voilà.
Ca peut vous paraître bizarre.
-Il fait des légumes,
mais il a fait sa mue.
-Oui, mais de temps en temps,
il y a aussi
les crustacés et le reste
et en même temps,
c'est un homme qui a une virtuosité
extraordinaire. Il sait tout faire.
Et alors,
on a fait réaliser, c'est Robert
Reiplinger qui a fait réaliser
la tête de veau
par Passard, un jour,
en croûte de sel.
L'important, c'est de la cuire
à l'étouffée.
-Oui.
-Une autre fois dans une marmite
au vin jaune, qui a dû
lui coûter cher quand même.
-Vous connaissez, ça, le vin jaune.
-Une autre fois avec des feuilles
de... de mûrier ou de...
je ne sais plus très bien,
de mûrier ou de... je ne sais plus.
-C'était très bon
chaque fois.
-C'était très bon.
-Les clients sont
terrifiés. Quand le chef apporte
la tête de veau entière...
-C'est assez impressionnant.
-Oui.
-C'est souvent autour d'un bon repas
que se nouent les deals politiques,
la petite et la grande histoire,
c'est la Brève de comptoir.
Alors, c'est souvent effectivement
autour des déjeuners, des dîners,
qu'on se raconte
les meilleures histoires,
on vous a demandé de réfléchir
à une anecdote. J'imagine que
vous avez fait des tas et des tas
de déjeuners et de dîners
politiques. Avez-vous un souvenir
à nous raconter ?
-J'ai pas vraiment réfléchi,
puisque tout à l'heure
on évoquait ce dîner
avec la reine d'Angleterre,
à l'ambassade de Grande-Bretagne,
c'est un souvenir assez douloureux
et émouvant. Donc ce vin
d'Angleterre nous est servi.
Et c'était la fameuse année
horribilis, je crois que c'est 1992.
Et la reine, nous étions
4 ou 5 à une petite table,
avec François Mitterrand
et son époux,
elle nous a livré
sa douleur.
Sa souffrance, qui était
absolument étonnante
de la part d'un personnage
qu'on disait retenu, réservé.
C'était une marque d'affection
pour François Mitterrand.
-De confiance aussi ?
-De confiance.
-Que vous a-t-elle dit ?
Quels ont été ses mots ?
-Je ne les ai pas exactement en
mémoire, mais ce qui était touchant,
c'est qu'elle nous parle et
qu'on sente en elle cette souffrance
qui a été la sienne
pendant plus d'un an.
-Cette fragilité aussi ?
-Cette humanité.
Et François Mitterrand
m'a dit d'ailleurs après le dîner,
j'ai rencontré souvent la reine,
c'est vrai,
il l'a rencontrée à Londres,
à l'inauguration
du tunnel sous la Manche, etc.
Elle est gentille.
Et pour moi,
le mot gentil est un beau mot.
-Qui est un peu galvaudé.
-Alors qu'on la présente parfois
comme rêche, comme dure.
J'ai eu la chance de l'accompagner
deux... trois jours
lors de ce voyage à Blois,
à Chambord,
à Bordeaux
où nous attendait leur bateau,
le Britannia,
et c'était une femme en effet,
dans le privé,
tel que je l'ai vécu, sûrement
j'ai été chanceux, délicieuse.
-Exquise.
-Comme vous travaillez
à l'IMA, à l'Institut du monde
arabe, nous nous sommes intéressés
à la cuisine du monde arabe.
Vous allez voir
qu'elle est riche
et variée. Le dessous des plats.
-Des pays du Maghreb
jusqu'au Proche-Orient
en passant par la péninsule
arabique, on déguste cette fameuse
cuisine arabe, élégante,
raffinée et riche
de multiples saveurs,
avec des plats cultes chez nous,
comme le couscous
et ses fameux mezzés,
ces entrées à partager.
Reportage de Clément Pérot,
d'Hélène Bonduelle
et de Sophia Mazhar.
-Le couscous a désormais
sa version fast-food.
Ils fleurissent un peu
partout en France,
les bars à couscous.
Le principe est simple, explications
avec Bader, installé à Paris,
près de la gare Saint-Lazare.
-On peut
composer son couscous
selon son envie,
en choisissant
les légumes, les semoules,
les viandes. C'est dans l'air
du temps. C'est optionnable,
on peut tout composer comme on en a
envie, pourquoi pas le couscous ?
-Navet, c'est ça ?
-Exact.
-OK. Ca ?
-Potiron.
-Potiron, ouais.
-On part sur carottes, potiron,
oignons, navets et pois chiches.
-Yes.
C'est le côté chaud et réconfortant
pour cette journée pluvieuse,
après, qu'on puisse choisir,
c'est un plus. Et à emporter,
encore mieux.
-On aime bien varier,
et puis, j'aime pas
quand c'est imposé aussi.
De changer le topping, la viande,
je trouve ça bien.
-Epicé pour la sauce ou normal ?
-Tout en haut du hit-parade
des garnitures...
-Les merguez.
Alors, même s'il est vrai que
les merguez, c'est une invention.
Les merguez, on n'a jamais eu de
couscous merguez, que ce soit
au Maroc, en Algérie ou en Tunisie.
C'est vrai. On doit l'avouer.
-Avec ou sans merguez,
le couscous reste le plat oriental
le plus populaire en France.
Mais une autre cuisine
du monde arabe, loin du Maghreb,
tire depuis des années
son épingle du jeu, c'est celle
du Liban. Ici, le grand classique,
l'incontournable,
c'est le houmous.
-C'est de la purée
de pois chiches, de la crème
de sésame au tahini,
de l'eau et du jus de citron.
Et à ça, on vient ajouter notre mix
spécial,
donc c'est des pois chiches cuits
avec des concombres en saumure,
des herbes fraîches, de la cébette.
Le houmous classique,
il est toujours sur la carte.
-Toujours sur la carte en compagnie
des mezzés, ces entrées à partager,
qui ont popularisé la cuisine
libanaise.
-Je pense que c'est
vraiment cet aspect du partage
qui fait le succès.
Aujourd'hui,
les gens ont envie de venir
et de passer un moment de partage.
-Cette variété permet aussi
de plaire à plusieurs personnes
et de ne pas se sentir bloqué
avec sa commande.
-C'est une cuisine
qui a un bon rapport qualité-prix
pour le déjeuner et c'est
une cuisine aussi assez conviviale
pour partager.
Donc les gens aiment bien
se retrouver ensemble
pour manger libanais.
-Rien qu'à Paris, la cuisine
libanaise compte
près de 250 adresses.
-Jack Lang, si je vous amène
dans un bar à couscous,
que mettez-vous
dans votre bol ?
Quels sont vos ingrédients,
votre garniture préférée ?
J'ai compris, pas de merguez, hein ?
-Pas de merguez, non, non.
Il a raison ce monsieur, bravo.
Il avoue d'ailleurs
son forfait, il dit,
j'introduis les merguez,
alors que ça n'existait pas.
Peut-être ça existe maintenant
en Algérie, au Maroc ou en Tunisie.
-Pour vous, c'est
une hérésie ?
-Je considère que c'en est une.
Elle est même pas mise à l'Institut
du monde arabe.
Je suis très franc avec vous.
-Alors, que mettez-vous
dans votre couscous idéal ?
-Pour moi,
le plus important,
c'est la qualité, évidemment
du couscous lui-même, la semoule,
j'aime la semoule
assez grosse,
d'autres l'aiment très fine.
Les légumes évidemment sont rois.
Il faut pas les couper
en petits morceaux,
il faut qu'ils arrivent
en pleine souveraineté.
Et les viandes.
Les viandes, mais on peut
s'en passer.
Un couscous de légumes...
-C'est un plat complet.
-S'il est
merveilleusement épicé, préparé,
c'est un plat complet.
-Donc pas forcément de l'agneau.
-Pas nécessairement,
non.
-Le méchoui,
c'est pas mal ?
-C'est autre chose.
-C'est une viande
qu'on peut mettre avec.
-Ce qui est bon, c'est
un vrai méchoui
que l'on déguste ensemble,
que l'on dévore avec les mains,
que l'on...
Un agneau
qu'on fait griller, c'est génial.
-Et les pois chiches,
les raisins secs ?
-C'est bien.
Ca agrémente un peu les choses.
-Vous connaissiez
le principe du bar à couscous,
c'est une bonne idée ?
-Je ne connais pas.
Vous me donnez l'idée
et je vous remercie. J'irai.
En plus, le monsieur est
sympathique. Je vais y courir.
-Il faut y goûter.
C'est un de vos plats préférés,
comme les Français
adorent le couscous ?
-J'aime, c'est pas mon plat préféré.
Si vous voulez, j'aime assez, j'aime
beaucoup la cuisine marocaine,
la cuisine algérienne ou tunisienne,
mais ça n'est pas le couscous
vers lequel
je me précipite. Ce sont
les tajines de viande,
les tajines de poisson,
les soupes aussi.
Pardon, je reviens aux soupes,
la chorba
ou la...
comment dirait-on au Maroc ?
Peu importe,
c'est le même principe.
Et puis certains
desserts...
-On en parlera tout à l'heure.
-Pardon.
-Ces tajines,
il y a... Oui ?
-Et les Maghrébins, les Algériens,
les Marocains, aussi les Tunisiens,
cuisinent admirablement
les poissons.
Ils les cuisinent au four,
en tajine. Je sais pas, ils ont
une façon... avec des aromates,
avec des épices.
Ils préservent à la fois
la qualité de la chair,
ils trouvent le moment juste
de cuisson et c'est parfumé,
admirablement.
-Vous aimez le côté aussi
salé-sucré dans certains tajines ?
-J'aime sans plus.
J'aime. J'aime. Sans plus.
C'est clair que les plats marocains
et algériens, je crois,
aux pruneaux,
sont bons, mais c'est pas...
-Ce que vous préférez.
-Et la cuisine
arabe, c'est aussi la cuisine
orientale, on parle souvent
de la cuisine libanaise,
une des meilleures
de cette région.
Vous êtes d'accord ?
-Oui. Je pense
que les 2 cuisines dominantes,
sans être offensant
à l'égard de personne,
c'est la cuisine marocaine
qui pousse à haut niveau,
c'est lié à une histoire, c'est lié
à beaucoup de choses.
Et la cuisine libanaise. Mais
n'oublions pas
celle qui a été la mère
de toutes les cuisines
de l'Orient, tout à l'heure,
on l'évoquait à propos
du loukoum, c'est la cuisine
ottomane, la Turquie.
-De l'Azerbaïdjan
jusqu'au Maroc, on mange ottoman.
-La Turquie n'a pas pour rien
été l'Empire ottoman
pendant 4 siècles.
Elle n'a pas pu ne pas
inspirer les cuisines,
même de l'Europe centrale.
-Et ce fameux houmous
qu'on voyait dans le reportage,
on le retrouve partout
au Moyen-Orient aujourd'hui.
-Partout.
-Un plat
qui a voyagé énormément.
Et les mezzés ?
-Le mot,
je ne sais pas s'il est libanais,
mais ce sont les Libanais
et les Turcs aussi,
c'est peut-être les Turcs à
l'origine, je pense, historiquement.
C'est merveilleux d'avoir
des petits plats de toutes sortes
dans lesquels on peut picorer. Comme
le disait la dame dans le reportage,
ça crée une atmosphère immédiatement
de partage et de convivialité.
Et on a le choix. Alors,
à l'Institut du monde arabe
dans le restaurant marocain
qui a été créé, ils ont aussi,
c'est Jamel Debbouze
qui a été l'un des inspirateurs,
ils ont été...
-Sa maman est aux fourneaux aussi.
-Au début, elle était là souvent.
C'est une femme merveilleuse,
que j'aime beaucoup,
en ce moment, elle n'est pas là,
j'espère qu'elle reviendra bientôt,
une femme délicieuse.
Elle a aidé beaucoup
à affiner la qualité
du couscous.
-C'est pas marocain,
les mezzés, on n'en mange pas
dans ce restaurant.
-Ils appellent mezzés...
-Les entrées.
-En réalité, au Maroc,
vous avez des petits hors-d'oeuvre.
Merveilleux souvent.
-Quels sont vos mezzés préférés ?
-Qu'à l'Institut du monde arabe,
ils appellent
improprement mezzés.
Enfin, c'est pas grave.
-Quels sont vos mezzés
préférés ? Les feuilles de vigne,
les poivrons farcis, la viande ?
-C'est quand ils sont bons, voilà.
-Et vous aimez un peu
ce côté finger food, où on peut
vraiment manger, grignoter,
passer d'un plat à l'autre ?
-J'aime beaucoup ça, d'ailleurs
je pousse cela à travers une manie,
dont j'ai du mal à me défaire,
c'est que j'aime utiliser ma cuiller
et ma fourchette pour puiser
dans le plat
central.
-C'est comme ça au Maghreb
en principe.
-Mais oui. C'est comme ça.
Un vrai couscous,
c'est au centre.
-Tout le monde se sert
et mange dans le même plat.
-Ce que fait notre ami
dans ses couscous
individuels, c'est bien, c'est
le cas à l'Institut du monde arabe,
ils sont excellents,
mais le vrai couscous...
-Dans les familles.
Vous imaginez, au restaurant,
je pense que l'hygiène...
-Si vous êtes une grande table,
mais c'est un plat familial.
-Les Chinois aussi aiment bien,
on met tout
autour de la table, ça tourne.
Ils aiment bien, ça.
En France effectivement,
on est un peu plus chacun pour soi.
-On a été marqués
par des siècles de monarchie,
qui ont introduit d'ailleurs
beaucoup de choses belles et bonnes,
la fourchette,
on dit que c'est Catherine
de Médicis qui l'aurait introduite.
-Ca vient d'Italie.
-On l'avait vu ici.
-Donc,
c'est vrai que, par exemple,
à la Révolution française,
lorsque les princes ont été
écartés du pouvoir,
les cuisiniers,
leurs cuisiniers sont devenus
des restaurateurs
et ont contribué à cette excellence
de la cuisine française.
-Et quand vous...
...voyagez ou quand vous revenez,
vous êtes content de retrouver
cette cuisine française ?
-Ou pas.
Parce que, tout à l'heure,
nous le disions,
je ne veux pas du tout être négatif,
mais aller au hasard
dans un restaurant,
c'est très difficile en France.
Aller au hasard
dans un restaurant en Italie,
vous êtes sûr d'être bien reçu.
-Alors,
au Parlement,
on parle beaucoup d'immigration
et notamment de la régularisation
des étrangers
dans les métiers en tension.
Alors a-t-on besoin de cette
main-d'oeuvre, on en parle
et on met les Pieds dans le plat.
Des restaurants fermés,
principalement
pour manque de main-d'oeuvre,
ça ne fait plus exception.
La restauration n'attire plus,
en dépit de salaires en hausse.
Les horaires et le stress
du service détournent
les jeunes de ces métiers
comme l'ont constaté
Clément Pérot et Yvana Navion.
-L'Escale est une institution.
Le plus grand resto routier
de France,
installé près de Châteauroux,
sert tous les jours de 400
à 600 couverts. Tous les jours,
mais plus toute l'année.
L'établissement connaît
des périodes
de fermeture.
-Je suis obligé de fermer
une semaine la semaine prochaine
par manque d'effectif, de personnel,
particulièrement en salle.
Plus personne ne veut
servir, plus personne
ne veut travailler
surtout le soir, le week-end,
c'est catastrophique.
Madame, monsieur, bonjour.
2 couverts ?
Si vous voulez bien me suivre.
-Longtemps ouvert 24/24,
l'Escale ferme
désormais à minuit pour ces raisons.
Alors qu'il a la clientèle pour
les remplir, le patron est contraint
de laisser certaines salles vides.
-C'est triste, hein.
Et si j'étais seul
à constater ce truc-là,
mais... un collègue, à côté, là,
il ferme tous les dimanches
depuis le 15 octobre
à cause de ? Manque de personnel.
Moi, ça fait 45 ans que je fais ça,
je suis pas mort, hein.
-L'Escale propose à ses serveurs
un salaire de 14,50 euros minimum
de l'heure. 2,20 euros de plus
que la moyenne de la profession,
mais ça ne suffit pas
à susciter des vocations.
En cuisine aussi, la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre se fait sentir.
-Bonjour. Là, ça va ramer.
-Au pic du déjeuner,
pour travailler ici, il faut dépoter
et apprécier l'adrénaline.
-Seb, j'ai 2 choucroutes.
-Courir partout, être dans le jus,
c'est passionnant.
-Pourquoi ?
-Je fais ça depuis que j'ai 13 ans
et ça changera pas.
J'adore. Faire la cuisine,
il faut aimer.
Sinon on peut pas tenir.
-Cassolette à suivre !
-Oui !
-Une frite en brasserie !
-Oui.
-Tartine du chauffeur !
-Oui !
-Pression, horaires contraignants,
salaires pas toujours
mirobolants, la restauration
n'attire plus. En salle,
les habitués sont au courant
des difficultés de l'Escale.
Chacun a son avis
sur la question.
-C'est normal
qu'ils en trouvent pas.
On leur donne tous les mois
de l'argent à rester chez eux.
-Chez les jeunes, faut pas
grand-chose pour être dégoûté.
Ca, c'est mon avis.
-Les métiers de la restauration,
c'est mal payé.
Vous commencez à 10h,
vous finissez à minuit,
si vous avez des enfants,
c'est impossible à gérer.
-Actuellement, l'Escale cherche
à recruter 5 serveurs en salle
et 3 cuisiniers.
-Avez-vous pu constater
cette tension
dans la restauration ? A l'IMA,
vous êtes concernés ?
-Oui, c'est un vrai sujet.
C'est un vrai sujet et je crois
que les autorités ont raison
de favoriser
le maintien,
la régularisation, pardon,
des personnes qui travaillent
dans ces métiers.
C'est quand même le minimum.
-Donc, pour vous,
ce fameux article 3 du projet
de loi immigration, il faudrait
qu'on puisse régulariser
automatiquement
les personnes
dans les métiers en tension ?
-Mais c'est... Je ne veux pas entrer
dans le détail technique,
mais je trouve un peu nul,
pour des raisons peut-être
purement politiques de soulever
une telle question. C'est
une évidence que nous avons besoin
de ces personnes,
pas seulement dans les métiers
de la restauration,
mais dans les métiers de la santé,
dans les hôpitaux, partout.
Des gens qui par ailleurs apportent
une compétence, un engagement,
un dévouement extrême.
-Ca va pas créer un appel d'air,
comme le dit la droite ?
-Ce sont des bêtises absolues.
Vous imaginez
qu'un pauvre homme qui souffre
dans le désert de l'Afrique
pense à l'article
3 lorsqu'il...
-Non, mais
il pense
qu'il y a un monde meilleur
en France.
-Sans doute.
-S'il voit qu'on régularise.
-C'est pas un article
qui le fait venir ou pas.
-Ca rend la France
plus attractive, non ?
-Ca préserve des métiers,
ça préserve des entreprises,
les entreprises de restauration,
les entreprises de toutes sortes,
et je crois que c'est vraiment...
c'est très mal d'avoir,
j'espère d'ailleurs
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale,
on va rectifier le tir.
-On veut aller plus loin
que la circulaire
Valls et pourtant,
un gouvernement socialiste,
sous François Hollande, avait mis
des garde-fous. L'employeur devait
faire la demande et pas le salarié,
ça, ça devrait changer. Et qui avait
laissé aux préfets la main
pour décider.
-Certes,
mais tous les gouvernements
de gauche n'ont
pas toujours fait
les meilleures choses. Ils ont fait
de bonnes choses, mais ils ont pu
se tromper. Et le temps a changé.
C'est mon avis personnel
et le sentiment des professionnels,
de tous les gens qui...
des utilisateurs de ces lieux,
non, il faut absolument revenir
à une situation sage et raisonnable.
-Il y a quand même
encore plus de 7 %
de chômage en France.
Des Français pourraient exercer
ces métiers. Vous pensez
que les Français ne veulent plus
les exercer ?
-C'est une situation de fait
que vous avez aujourd'hui en France,
j'ai pas en mémoire les chiffres...
-3 millions de chômeurs.
-Oui, de chômeurs,
mais le chiffre
que je n'avais pas en tête, c'est
le nombre de non-Français
qui occupent ces métiers.
Et je pense que si, déjà, on ne
trouve pas... c'est une évidence.
-On a le droit de dire,
au lieu de donner ces jobs
à ces sans-papiers
ou à ces migrants,
donnons-les aux Français
au chômage.
-S'ils viennent, ils les auront.
Il y a parfois aussi, je ne veux pas
rentrer dans le détail
de ce que je ne connais pas bien,
mais il y a aussi
des conditions de travail,
des conditions de salaire,
que je connais...
-Et d'horaires aussi.
-D'horaires. Par exemple, je connais
des gens qui travaillent
de très tôt le matin
et qui terminent très tard le soir.
-C'est pour ça,
les Français aujourd'hui ne veulent
plus accepter ce genre de travail
ou c'est aussi assez inhumain
et de se dire que ce n'est pas
normal qu'un étranger exerce...
-Il faut s'attaquer à ces horaires.
-A cette organisation.
-Qui est assez dure
et assez difficile à vivre.
Pour leur famille. C'est vraiment...
Je pense que cette question qui
a été soulevée devrait être réglée
d'une manière, non pas sous la forme
d'exclusion, mais sous la forme
d'une mesure sociale concernant
l'organisation du travail
et les salaires.
-Les salaires ont augmenté
de plus de 16 % dans la restauration
l'année dernière.
Et pourtant,
ça n'attire toujours pas,
donc c'est l'organisation
qui est à revoir ?
-Ce sont des métiers
très difficiles. Comme je suis
moi-même un amoureux
des bistrots et des restaurants,
je vois comment ils bossent,
et il faut beaucoup de courage,
de temps et ne pas avoir de famille
parfois. Ne pas avoir d'amis,
ne pas avoir d'activité.
-En sacrifier une partie.
-Il faut régler cette question
de manière sage
et pas politicienne.
-Humaine ?
-Humaine, voilà. Vous avez
trouvé le bon mot.
-Dans ce reportage,
un des clients dit,
beaucoup de gens préfèrent
rester chez eux,
car ils sont mieux payés.
Il faudrait faire
une plus grande différence
entre les revenus du travail
et ceux de l'assistance ?
-Ecoutez, c'est faux ce qu'il dit.
C'est faux.
Les revenus de l'assistance
ne sont pas si élevés qu'on le dit.
C'est en partie une légende.
Et il y a des gens
qui sont assistés,
car ils ne peuvent pas travailler.
Si on veut mettre dans des bistrots,
des restaurants ou les hôpitaux,
des personnes qui ont un handicap
provisoire, faisons-le. Je trouve
que, quand on est homme politique
ou femme politique, c'est pas
une question de droite et de gauche
selon moi, c'est une question
de responsabilité.
Ne traitons pas les choses
comme ça pour tenter de plaire à...
D'ailleurs, je suis convaincu
que les citoyens de base,
quelle que soit leur opinion,
partagent le sentiment
que j'exprime à l'instant
et qui sera développé ou retenu
par l'Assemblée nationale.
-Comme
le disent les sondages.
-Dans une certaine gauche monte
un droit à la paresse revendiqué,
vous qui êtes
dans la gauche old fashioned,
revendiquez-vous
ce droit à la paresse ?
-Je me considère
comme new fashioned.
-Pardon.
-Je plaisante.
Euh... Bah le droit...
Oui, le droit à la jouissance.
Le droit au plaisir,
le droit au désir.
-Paresse et plaisir,
c'est pas pareil.
-Non.
-Le droit à la paresse,
vous le revendiquez ?
Et cette valeur travail qui a moins
d'importance chez les jeunes ?
Comment vous le sentez ?
-Oui, ça, c'est une chose à étudier.
C'est vrai
que c'est un changement de mentalité
assez fort qui se produit.
On dit que c'est lié au Covid.
Peut-être. C'est vrai que,
dans tous les sujets que je connais,
pas seulement celui-là,
il y a eu un changement
de comportement.
Des gens n'acceptent plus
des emplois trop durs,
s'ils ont la possibilité
d'avoir des emplois aussi bien payés
ou même moins bien payés,
mais moins astreignants.
J'imagine que les autorités
y travaillent.
-On dit, les jeunes ne veulent plus
travailler,
c'est pas des tire-au-flanc ?
-N'exagérons pas. On vit de slogans,
de qu'en-dira-t-on,
les jeunes, quand ils ont la chance
de pouvoir faire
des études passionnantes
ou d'être engagés
dans un métier excitant,
ils bossent,
ils travaillent, ils aiment ça.
-Ils veulent peut-être
un meilleur équilibre.
-Peut-être et après tout,
ils ont raison.
-Alors, on va passer au dessert
et c'est le Péché mignon.
-Jack Lang a voulu
une omelette norvégienne.
Ca a été créé en 1867
par un chef qui s'appelait Balzac,
le chef du Grand Hôtel,
qui a voulu créer
un dessert un peu scientifique,
en montrant que le blanc d'oeuf,
la meringue,
est un isolant entre la chaleur,
il y avait une génoise flambée
et de la glace. Avec une meringue,
ça ne conduisait pas.
C'est quand même
compliqué, de la glace,
du flambage,
même ce plat iconique,
ce dessert iconique
a disparu progressivement
des tables. Alors, nous,
on va vous servir
une omelette norvégienne
qui n'a plus grand-chose
de norvégienne, sinon le nom.
Faites pas la fine bouche, M. Lang.
-Non, mais d'accord.
-Compte tenu des dispositions
de cette cuisine.
-Elle est pas flambée,
on est désolés.
-Vous m'avez demandé,
entre 2 portes,
si j'ose dire,
quel plat je proposais.
Je pense qu'on doit réhabiliter,
je suis pour l'innovation,
pour la recherche,
la découverte de nouvelles saveurs,
évidemment, mais le pot-au-feu,
nous l'avons évoqué,
et l'omelette norvégienne,
c'est un plat que j'ai
connu quand ma mère était
ma cuisinière, si j'ose dire.
C'est un plat beau d'abord.
Pas comme ça,
pardon. Il arrive,
c'est une sorte de montagne
blanche,
qui est arrosée,
alors, selon les endroits,
dans mon pays,
c'était de mirabelle,
et qu'on fait flamber.
Le plat arrive flambé.
-C'est déjà un spectacle.
-C'est interdit ici,
à l'Assemblée.
-Et puis,
comme vous l'avez
très bien expliqué,
c'est 3 couches, c'est une génoise
qui est le fond du plat,
une glace et des blancs d'oeuf.
Le tout évidemment est
de réaliser...
Il faut que ça se tienne.
-Votre maman vous a-t-elle
légué la recette et arrivez-vous
à reproduire cette recette ?
-Je sais encore la faire.
-Ah bon ?
-Oui, je sais encore la faire.
-On n'en trouve
quasiment pas à la carte.
-Je connais un restaurant,
mais est-ce qu'on a le droit
de faire la publicité
pour les restaurants ? Là encore,
c'est mon ami Robert Reiplinger,
qui est un gastronome,
je ne sais pas
s'ils le font régulièrement
ou s'ils le font à la demande, c'est
le Louis XIII.
-Avec un nom pareil, il peut.
Rires
-Elle est née après Louis XIII.
Comme vous l'avez
très bien dit,
elle n'est pas norvégienne.
-J'ai une anecdote.
En fait, le fameux Balzac, le chef,
voulait rendre hommage
à un physicien qui avait
imaginé ce blanc d'oeuf
non conducteur
et qui était installé en Bavière.
Le pauvre Balzac croyait
que c'était en Norvège, il a baptisé
son omelette ainsi.
C'est drôle.
-C'est une omelette
allemande.
-Bavaroise.
-On peut le croire,
parce que le blanc des neiges,
le blanc des glaces,
la glace elle-même.
C'est merveilleux.
J'allais dire, si on va jusqu'en
Islande, les volcans qui flambent.
-C'est ça,
on s'y croirait.
-Il avait de l'imagination
et il a choisi...
-Il ne connaissait pas
la géographie.
-Donc, réhabilitons
ce type de plat. Ca vaut
pour beaucoup d'autres choses,
notamment pour les desserts.
Je trouve qu'il y avait
des plats anciens
qui étaient d'une saveur extrême.
Je suis en train de...
-En tous les cas, c'est
le nouveau combat de Jack Lang.
-C'est un combat permanent.
-Permanent. Alors,
on termine toujours en musique,
on va écouter
celle que vous avez choisie
et vous nous direz ce que c'est.
"Einstein On The Beach",
Philip Glass
...
-C'est Philip Glass, c'est ça ?
"Einstein On The Beach".
-Philip Glass,
qui est un compositeur américain,
qui est un des inventeurs
de ce qu'on appelle
la musique répétitive
et qui accompagne en particulier,
je crois, à nouveau
bientôt à La Villette,
une mise en scène de Bob Wilson,
que nous avons contribué
à faire découvrir à Nancy
il y a une vingtaine d'années.
Personnellement,
j'aime la musique répétitive,
pas seulement Philip Glass.
J'aime les musiques
traditionnelles,
la musique balinaise
ou la musique africaine,
parce qu'elles sont à base
souvent de répétitions, de rythmes.
J'aime aussi
la musique électronique.
C'est une partie
de mes goûts musicaux.
-Grâce à vous,
nous avons la Fête
de la Musique
et on vous en remercie.
Merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation,
merci de nous avoir
suivis, on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...